how to promote a fashion show so I've
got a great question one of my
newsletter readers love you guys
Aditi who wrote in to say hey Evan my
dad has a garment business we're going
to have our very first fashion show this
September I want to make sure it gets a
media coverage before and after the
fashion show to create the hype to get
maximum sales
can you help and can you give me some
idea on how I can get guys and girls to
model in our fashion show without having
to pay them because I want to keep a low
budget show to get the maximum returns
Thank You Aditi so it's a great question
and I have three pieces of advice for DT
number one is be different what is so
different about this fashion show right
you haven't told there are million
people launching fashion shows fashion
lines everybody wants to be a fashion as
I know everybody launching t-shirt lines
and whatever clothing line they want to
put out that there's so many people
doing this that it's not news so what is
different about your company what are
you staying for what are you trying to
accomplish with this besides just making
money what impact do you trying to have
in the world you want to share this
tell me what's different and unique and
special about this fashion show and
every time you're talking about it
you're using that to get people excited
right
I should be getting excited I mean I'm
excited but I should be getting even
more excited by the cause that you're
creating behind this what's so different
unique and special about your fashion
line right you haven't told me you're
just saying and put it on the fashion
show on to be great well what's
different about it it's going to make it
great right you have to know what you're
standing for here and that's going to
get people excited so number one is be
different
number two is get partners anytime
you're trying to launch something new
the fastest way to market is to partner
with people who already have your
audience so think about the ideal people
who you want to have coming to your show
I don't know who it is if it's fashion
buyers it was young professionals
whoever it is say you're targeting young
professionals just for the example you
want to work with other companies who
are not direct competitors to you who
also sell to young professionals and
invite
the common participate and maybe you
give them a booth at the back maybe you
give them space on your website whatever
it is you want them promoting your event
to their customer saying that they're
going to be there and if you get 10 or
20 of these people to all promote it and
bring their audience then it's a fast
way to generate lots of people coming to
your event so partner up and number
three is connect with the media the
media they care about a story you
understand the media when you're writing
to reporters you're writing to bloggers
you write into social media people they
are constantly looking for content right
if you're writing to a reporter they
need content daily and so you're making
their job easier by giving them great
content but you have to give them great
content and it comes from your number
one and you number two right what what
does it show why is it different and
who's involved in this program if you
write to report with what you sent me
you're not going to get any response
right I'm putting on this fashion show
wanted to be great that's not something
a reporter cares about right make my
life easy as a reporter and tell me what
is so special unique amazing awesome
about this fashion show and who is
involved in it besides you and now
you're creating the story that I can
write about I'd also target the
non-traditional media so it's great to
go after reporters TV newspapers all of
that stuff radio shows and it's easy to
find their access right you just go to
their websites get their email address
and you can write to them and when I
first started my business that's what I
would do is every week create a new
story not just a press release marketing
crap a real story that I would send out
to the list and every week somebody
picked it up and put it in their
magazine or have me on TV or having me
on their radio show so this works that's
traditional I'd also look at
non-traditional the new online media
look at bloggers look at people of
popular Twitter bases YouTube bases
Facebook bases who are in your local
area and are selling to the same people
you're selling to because bloggers need
content and want to share something cool
and people who are making YouTube videos
like me you know you're giving
content to create this video right
you're giving me a question that I turn
into content as creators we're all
looking for new content to talk about
and your fashion show could be it if you
reach out to me and tell me what your
purpose is why your thing is so
different and who's involved in the
program so remember number one be
different number two get partners and
number three connect with media believe
those are watching like the video you
can support me please by clicking on the
link in the description that helps me
keep these videos going leave a comment
let me know what you think and click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon